what up king in this thing this is
Brennan from Lafayette Louisiana I got a
[ __ ] debate club when you park do you
back into the place or do you pull in
like a normal [ __ ] I mean I think if
you're robbing something for you or
stealing or you are doing adultery you
back in yeah you need to get out fast
yeah there you go
but I pulling like your goddamn tanks
every time front dog do you yeah dude
I'm not trying to steal anything you
look ridiculous with the bandana I know
it is and you have the right to look
ridiculous and I respect that
thank you I'm sorry man I said actually
pulling up a tic-tac of Theo's no no
talk for them kids is this back in what
do you guys do you back in or what do
you do back in evaluated for six years
oh you drove LA yeah really ever ding
the cars and [ __ ] was good sometimes and
boys of the Comba store ding the the
doors and oh yeah park your [ __ ] yeah
remember there just it was a college
trying to make it they know how to drive
cars yes suddenly back like Oh cuz this
guy can do riddles and stuff he can do
it most about a drive stick either which
is shocking to me to like we're learning
anymore so what was your big move what
well how would you save time really what
do you mean when you how would you save
time when you were valet yeah we bet we
back them all in really yeah that was
the quickest really I'd say so
see man I think if you have that type of
work ethic and ability you got to get
into this so that's where I was going
with this take the same confidence you
have with backing in cars to your
barbecue business students guys serenity
in back that recipe
into the kettle brother yeah get a
kettle get a two-weeks give me a chance
okay i'll people jump up look we gave
you one week and you bought a gold chain
so I feel you bro I respect it it's a
very Brendan style way to do things so
you've learned from your sensei I get it
but the second week right you gotta go
[Music]